[Music]
hi Neil welcome to my channel hi Justine
it's great to be with you thank you very
much for making the time I am so excited
to chat with you and before we get
started do you want to introduce
yourself to my audience so they can get
to know you a little bit better sure
yeah so uh my name is Neil Mohan I'm the
new leader of YouTube after my long time
friend and Mentor Susan wojcicki
announced that she was stepping back I
think it's been a whirlwind I think
about a week ago or maybe a little bit
longer but uh very new to my brand new
role heading up YouTube but I have been
at YouTube for a very long time I've
been at YouTube now for seven years and
some of your audience might know me as
the guy who was responsible for all of
our products and user design and also
our trust and safety and content
policies and so I've been very familiar
of course with all the products that
that all of our creators use all of our
viewers enjoy on a regular basis before
YouTube I was at Google for a very long
time I was responsible for a lot of our
ad products here and my career has
really been building tools and AD
products and things like that for
Content creators whether on YouTube or
across the internet Etc and just a very
kind of anecdote that very few people
knew about but was a was was something I
mentioned in the letter that I sent out
yesterday to the YouTube Community is
I've been working with YouTube before
either I or YouTube were part of Google
I remember visiting YouTube when it was
a you know a startup in the uh above a
pizza parlor in downtown San Mateo where
it was the company was started and just
remembering like how crazy uh fast this
company was growing and all the feedback
I was getting from Founders at the time
was like can my products keep up with
the growth of YouTube Etc and then fast
forward a decade and a half later this
incredible Creator economy that exists
people like you creators business people
Etc experiencing and enormous success on
our platform and so that's a little bit
about my background and my involvement
with YouTube yeah I mean it's wild and I
think you know Susan has obviously done
so much for Google and for YouTube so
we're definitely going to miss her but I
know she has promised us that we're in
good hands so I'm so excited to talk to
you more about kind of your plans and
things like that but it really is wild
to think about I mean I've been on
YouTube for almost 17 years maybe longer
than that I guess a lot of creators and
of course me included are wondering how
do you think YouTube will change or how
will it look under your leadership so
what would you say to them you know I'll
start off with what I think is not going
to change and Susan and I had the
privilege of working with her almost
every day for 15 years and so a lot of
what I think creators in our community
can expect is a lot of continuity
particularly in one area which was very
important to Susan and is going to be my
top priority which is spending time with
creators and building products and
services that are about making our
creators successful on YouTube as you
know through your own experience
creators are the lifeblood of YouTube
all of the viewers all of your all of
the fans come to the YouTube product
every day because they want to engage
with you they want to interact with you
one thing I will say that obviously I
should I should acknowledge is that the
environment that we're in uh the
macroeconomic environment you know some
of the uncertainty in the world I do
think that those are things that
manifest in our creators business in
terms of how they think about their
presence on our platform and so paying
particular attention to that to make
sure that we come out of this uncertain
times even stronger and really write the
next chapter of YouTube which I'm
extremely extremely optimistic about
yeah it's super exciting and I mean your
letter was pretty extensive and it
covered so much so do you want to kind
of give us just a quick little overview
of everything that you mentioned I mean
I think that the way I I try to organize
it in sort of the way that I think about
it in my own head is um really kind of
three buckets and the first bucket and
where I started the letter on purpose is
a lot of what I just said which is about
supporting creators and so you have seen
some of the work that we've done over
the last few months in terms of
revamping our monetization program
bringing monetization to shorts the
expansion of our ypp to include a fan
funding tier and on and on and so just
really focusing on helping our creators
build businesses on our platform finding
ways to better support their businesses
so that can be everything from you know
ad supported to channel memberships to
Super Chat to all of those types of
opportunities that we're working on that
is one area of priority for me that was
sort of the first bucket other things
like you know multi-track audio being
able to extend audiences as both
audience growth opportunities but also
business opportunities fell into that
buckets that's the first area that is
that's a priority for me and I wanted to
call that out the second of course is
making sure that YouTube is set up for
the future that we're investing in our
background has been at the try to be at
The Cutting Edge of innovation and I
want to continue that forward and so you
know a couple examples in that bucket
are making it so that the living room
screen the large screen that people have
in their homes television screen what
have you which is our largest and
fastest growing screen is one that we
continue to invest in and so what that
means is bringing the magic of YouTube
that all of our viewers know and enjoy
when they pick up their mobile phones to
that living room screen and so
interactivity for example being able to
connect with their favorite creators on
that screen bringing the shorts
experience to that screen but also
investing in new ways of creation so I
think you know this like the line
between sort of creation and consumption
is a blurry line so making sure that we
have the right set of creative tools
investing in our camera effects and
things like that and then also
supporting all formats when it comes to
creation and so one of the areas I'm
very excited about this year where we
have a lot in stores podcasts I know
that's something that's important to you
but also to lots of other creators and
so how do we make it work seamlessly in
studio from a tool standpoint how do we
bring you know distribution to podcast
content by bringing it to the YouTube
music app and things like that and then
finally kind of what underpins the third
bucket of course that under underpins
the first two buckets is we're a global
platform continuing to live up to our
responsibility to keep our entire
community of viewers creators Partners
safe but also making sure it's an
enjoyable experience by investing in
things like policies enforcement of
those policies to do the right thing for
our creators and so that's the third
bucket and so I wanted to highlight all
three of those as areas of priority for
me and where the company is going to
invest in in 2023. some
bring up but
but thing about is a AI now obviously I
know Google has been talking about Bard
and all the things that they're doing as
well so how do you see AI kind of
changing the way that YouTube operates
as a whole so the first thing that I'll
say about that and you're right there is
a lot of talk in the industry about it
we read about it we watch videos about
it every single day it's been an area
that frankly at YouTube we've been
investing in for years and I'll just
give you some examples I mean you open
up the app you see the home feed there's
recommendations in that home feed I
finish watching one of your videos I'm
recommending a bunch of videos right
below that in on the watch page that is
a product of AI That's Awesome us
investing very heavily in machine
learning algorithms deep learning to
make it so those recommendations get
better and better and better which
obviously helps our creators but also
makes YouTube YouTube for our viewers
and so that's been going on for years I
mentioned responsibility all the work
that we do to make sure that we are
dealing with anything that might be
harming our creators or our viewers
whether it's abuse or scams or other
sorts of deceptive practices I think the
area that that I would you know kind of
build on there is a lot of what's being
talked about in terms of generative AI
right you can imagine the tools that I
was describing around creation getting
augmented through this technology and so
everything from being able to change
your outfit on the fly or your hair
color on the fly or what the background
is puts you in a different job fixed
pixelation in um in a video remove
something that is distracting from the
background in the video that you're
working with on and on and on so that
our creators can focus on the actual
creative part of the process and let the
magic of AI take care of the rest and
it's in the term generative AI we are in
the business of helping content creation
be generate you know content be
generated on our platform and that is
where you should expect YouTube uh to be
focused in terms of our investments
going into the rest of 20 2023 but
actually more importantly for years to
come yeah I think now cut buzzword
that's being tossed around AI is mostly
thinking about generative art you know
chat gbt like these sorts of things but
like people sometimes don't even realize
that the algorithm and the the
recommendation engine all of that stuff
is also AI so it's I'm glad you kind of
brought that up because I feel like
there is some misconception of what is
this AI machine like what does it do I
know personally I'm waiting for an AI
generated thumbnail designer because
I've been making thumbnails for 17 years
and for some reason I just can't give up
that or I think you know in that example
it might be that the first place where
AI can really help there is to augment
that creative process because that is
part of your process that's like part of
the product that you're putting out
there and for your for your audience but
if there's things that the that AI can
do to make that process more seamless
and efficient so that you can focus on
the creative aspect of the thumbnail
that would be a win for for my team as
well and so it's about potentially
generating the full thumbnail but it's
also about actually giving you tools to
make it easier for for you to go about
doing what you've already been doing
right even things like you know changing
titles or descriptions or helping kind
of assist with that I mean because I
feel like you get so exhausted after
you're done with this whole content
procedure you're like oh my gosh I need
a I need a title I mean we're at this
weird kind of point where I feel like I
always trust everything that AI says as
the full truth so I've definitely had an
AI write me a script and I'm like wait a
minute you're making this up like this
is not actually anything that's that's
true so like is there anything that
YouTube has been doing to kind of help
kind of stop these false narratives it's
a really interesting question and I
think it's going to be one where that
story is going to continue to evolve
frankly as the technology starts to get
out there and more and more products it
is front and center in the conversation
today and all I can say about that is we
have invested very heavily in
recognizing that um what happens on
YouTube impacts the real world and vice
versa and what that means is really
living up to our responsibility to be a
platform that isn't you know spreading
harmful misinformation or what have you
our community guidelines the way that we
enforce them all that will continue to
apply the scale will certainly change
and so we need to remain Vigilant in
that regard and that's something that
the teams at YouTube have on their radar
that we're going to continue to make
sure we are staying ahead of the other
thing that I'll say which your your
question brings up is how these
Technologies are actually brought to
market in terms of products and so I
think that that's an area too where I
think we have to be responsible actors
and so one of the ways that we think
about incorporating generative AI into
say our creation tools is to look at
things through that lens could they be
used could they be misappropriated in
certain way abused in a certain way and
so being very responsible and thoughtful
about how we bring these tools to the
market to our creators to our viewers
Etc is another important part I think of
the product development process yeah
really great and I'm just glad that you
guys are kind of forward thinking
because obviously you guys you guys such
a a huge Marketplace so I feel like kind
of setting that as a standard is very
important for the industry as a
long-form content creator shorts has
just come in and kind of Taken Everybody
by storm and it's a whole different way
of I feel like creating content because
I love making vertical videos at first
you know back when everyone started
doing it I was like I'm not really sure
if I'm into this like let's flip our
cameras around I remember like yelling
at my parents like no don't film
vertical and now I'm like you have to
film vertical I'm like please switch it
I guess as a long form content creator
is there anything that we should be
concerned about like are you guys going
to still be a supporting long form or
kind of moving more towards shorts yeah
I mean I'll just I'll just say it's
straight for me and just so that you and
your your audience hear it you know long
form and it's it's you know it's funny
that we use a long form term because
that was the original short form when
you started back in the day and so right
so that's been core to YouTube will all
will remain core to YouTube not just
this year but for many years to come
what is interesting about short form is
that it is something that all augments
The long-form Experience on YouTube both
for creators and our viewers it's not
just even between short form and long
form I like to talk about it in terms of
true multi-format capabilities and so
whether it's something that you want to
share with your audience that's 15
seconds long or 15 minutes long or a 15
hour live stream you want to do YouTube
should be the place that you can do that
and build an audience around that and
build a business around that you can add
to that not just live and long form
content in shorts but also audio content
we I mentioned podcasts earlier whatever
way you want to express yourself as a
Creator and connect with your audience
YouTube should be the place that allows
you to do that we're going to continue
to invest in that both in terms of
Creator tools but also in terms of
audiences discovering that but that is
meant to be part of this broad
multi-format Journey as opposed to
something that is short versus long yeah
I love it because I do feel like even
before I would feel like I would unbox
something that I could have probably
done in a minute but I would stretch
that out until 10 minutes long and I'm
like that did not need to be a 10 minute
video like I could have just done this
in like 15 to like 35 seconds so I love
kind of having that other Avenue to be
able to just create different types of
content that might not otherwise fit my
normal Pipeline and I think the
interesting thing there
um is that you should be able to connect
your audience across these formats too
right there's sort of a path that your
audience can take if they're consuming
shorts then they can continue to consume
shorts but they can also move shorts to
your longer form from shorts to your
longer form videos or what have you as
somebody who has invested in long form
for such a long time and um you know you
obviously produce a lot of short form
content too you're great at it how do
you think about the distinction between
those two types of types of content do
you think about them differently
vis-a-vis your audience or topics or
kind of how do you think about that as
you go about your week yeah I mean I'm
still kind of trying to figure it out as
I think everyone is but what I've Loved
about kind of this vertical content is
it kind of reminds me of the early days
of YouTube when I first started making
content it's almost like I can be more
myself like I could just be sillier in
like this little 15 to like a minute
bite-sized chunks it's kind of
reinvigorated sort of my content
creation because I don't have to
sometimes feel like I have to be so
serious like I have to sit down have a
script have a plan and talk for 10
minutes like I can just show you my dog
I can show you my day or I can give you
a one minute breakdown of a new piece of
tech you really can do anything and I
think that's why I'm so excited about
the future of it and you feel like your
audience sort of picks up on that Vibe
very quickly like they know that's their
expectation with your shorts content
versus your long form I think the
problem with my channel is they never
know what they're gonna get so I guess
it's pretty on brand that they're like
oh today she's at the premiere for
Mandalorian and tomorrow I don't know if
she's giving your dog a bath so it's
it's definitely on brand for for my
channel and I think that's why I've just
really loved it because it is just like
I said it's it's another way to kind of
just create yeah no that that makes a
ton of sense and it's an area that we're
going to continue to invest in kind of
tying back to your your AI question that
is where you can see a lot of the
Innovation showing up in that camera
right like you hit the plus button you
should be able to give a prompt that
allows you to change the background or
your outfit or what have you and then
kind of building from there yes is there
anything that we can look forward to I
mean especially like being able to
change the thumbnail like that's
definitely high on my wish list yeah um
that's that's a good question and so
that's that's feedback that we've gotten
on shorts and one of the reasons we
didn't start there immediately or it
didn't occur to us to start there
immediately is because of the the
consumption modality of shorts right
like you're consuming it in a feed like
autoplay type of an environment as you
see in the shorts player and that's
where most of the shorts views tend to
come from but we have gotten a lot of
the feedback I'm excited about is that
we're working we're gonna having a
capability both on Android and iOS where
uh you'll be able to pick the the the
frame from your short and make that the
thumbnail which is obviously a very
natural way to have the thumbnail for
shorts we have also gotten feedback from
creators about having parity between
shorts thumbnails and you know what you
just described Justine in terms of what
you do for long-form thumbnails it's a
conversation that we're having I think
there just to kind of call it out it's a
bit trickier because part of the shorts
is kind of what you just said right like
you can be more natural yourself
yourself it's less sort of prepared and
and if we introduce an element that like
that you have to do above and beyond
after having produced a short that sort
of becomes like this whole other thing
that gets added on to what otherwise
would have taken a minute or two then I
think it sort of defeats the purpose of
that short form content in the first
place and so that's a little bit of the
trade-off we're looking at especially if
thumbnails sort of become this
competitive thing just like they are on
on long form on shorts and we we don't
want that we don't want to create that
additional burden for for short form
creators but I guess I'm curious how do
you how do you think about that do you
think that having the ability to
actually pick the frame that you would
like as your custom frame thumbnail for
shorts is kind of sufficiently moves in
that direction I mean I like it I
definitely think like on the go I would
do that but then there's just something
about going to my channel and then
aesthetically like having like a curated
thumbnail even if it's something that
you don't see in the short speed it
would just be like a presentation kind
of like your channel as a package as a
whole like okay all of your thumbnails
line up you can do it like today or like
a week from now so it's not something I
feel like you would have to do
immediately but I definitely think in
the the near term having just being able
to choose that frame I think is super
helpful that's an interesting way of
sort of splitting those two things so
obviously to get the short up and
running being able to pick within the
frame so that you don't have that
post-production type burden kind of
piece but then potentially being able to
come back to it because these shorts do
live on and that are consumed you know
in future days and weeks kind of a thing
so yeah that's the way we're
prioritizing it is let's give creators
the ability to pick that frame
um on on on on both platforms as quickly
as possible but we are talking about
that longer term piece that you that you
brought up as well so that that's that's
really interesting feedback yeah I think
that's great but I'm super hyped on
shorts but also another thing is
monetization obviously that's top of
mind for almost all creators and it's
been kind of a controversial topic
recently with a lot of channels getting
demonetized with a lot of the new policy
changes so what can you say to those who
have been affected by this and what can
we do moving forward forward to ensure
that our content is still monetizable
it's a good question and as I said you
know in kind of my my introduction up
front like my entire career has been
really focused on helping creators and
content creators produce to generate
Revenue building ads products Building
monetization Products it's something
that's near and dear to my heart
um I know what you're referencing and so
and I'll come to the to your specific
question but just to give a broader
context we do make policy changes uh in
terms of our monetization policies from
time to time and really the purpose and
spirit behind those including the change
I think you're alluding to that happened
back in I think it's November Now is
really about increasing monetization for
our creators making it so that the
pathway from Advertiser demand to
Creator monetization is a smoother one
allows more content to be monetized at
higher rates and that was really the
spirit of the of the change that we
announced around profanity and things
like that in in the videos since then
we've heard the feedback back my teams
have heard the feedback loud and clear
and hopefully you'll be happy to hear
that we're taking that feedback into
account and figuring out ways that we
can potentially incorporate that
feedback I don't have anything specific
to say there today but stay tuned
because that feedback has been heard the
spirit of that change and any policy
change we make on monetization is to
really improve monetization for our
creators and so I want to take into
account that feedback that I've gotten
from creators be true to that original
Spirit of actually creating a policy
that drives more dollars to our creators
videos yeah I think that's the hard part
you know as a Creator who has been has
very clean content pretty much my entire
existence you know I've never had to
worry about that but it is hard
especially for those who have been
creating other types but also if I were
to be an Advertiser like I understand
because I wouldn't want to be
advertising my brand over you know that
type of content so I think sometimes
creators also have to think of it as an
Advertiser you know so I think there are
advertisers that would want to so it's a
very fine line so I'm glad that you guys
are you know working on that and
addressing it because I mean there's so
many creators out there with so many
different types of content that it's
really hard to kind of pick and choose
who can advertise on what yeah and
actually your your Insight is precisely
right like and so if you think about it
you know putting yourself in the shoes
of The Advertiser given all that amazing
choice that exists on YouTube which is
kind of the magic of YouTube you have to
make it so that it feels to The
Advertiser not just safe but relatively
clear in terms of where their
advertising is going to run to your
point because you know they don't want
to inadvertently damage their brand in
any particular way and so our policies
are really oriented towards that when I
say increase Creator monetization one of
the best ways to increase Creator
monetization is to make advertisers more
comfortable with the content and that is
the goal of our policy changes and so
but the feedback's been received and so
stay tuned so something else some
feedback speaking of I'm sure you don't
want to talk about it as I'm sure you've
been hearing about it non-stop but the
dislikes so how have you seen removing
dislikes improve the platform and what
metrics can we now use instead to see if
people actually like our videos I think
what might be most useful to your
audience is actually giving you a little
bit of color in terms of how we went
about making those types of product
decisions and that's actually how my
team operates on all sorts of decisions
we make and really it's about making
sure that we're doing the right thing
for the entire Community by balancing
creators and viewers and partners and
what have you and in this particular
case it was really about protecting our
creators and as we dug in in terms of
had the conversations got a lot of
feedback from creators and we got a lot
of feedback even before we roll this out
as you can imagine because what we
wanted to do was set up the right sorts
of tests and experiments to understand
whether the product change we were
designing was going to accomplish what
we wanted to and what we wanted to
accomplish was to protect creators from
you know dislike bombing those sort of
coordinated attacks that would happen
the defense eventually would start to
become a form of harassment and it was
our Theory going into it anecdotally
that creators that came from
underrepresented communities creators
that were smaller in nature were
disproportionately harmed by that type
of action and you can imagine just as
you know from where YouTube started
protecting those creators is a core part
of what YouTube is that is why there is
so much diversity of content and ideas
and and the like on YouTube and so we
ran the tests we ran the experiments and
we saw a few things the first is that
when you remove the count the incentive
for someone to dislike is lower so
that's Point number one that seems kind
of intuitive but that came across in the
testing the second is that actually it
was true that creators that were of that
smaller in nature underrepres presented
communities were disproportionately
subject to those types of dislike
attacks and then the third piece which
is impact on our viewers didn't actually
show up in terms of any change to the
relative distribution of views and watch
time on videos so it wasn't used as a
signal in that particular way at least
in terms of what our data showed and so
that gave us the conviction to remove it
now it's been about a year we've gone
back and looked at the data and what I
can tell you is that those things that
we were seeing in the experiment ended
up being roughly true both in terms of
Creator impact sort of the positive
impact in terms of protecting creators
from those types of dislike attacks but
also in terms of negligible impact on
viewers for that reason I feel like not
only did we go about the decision in the
right way and I recognize it's always a
trade-off these are especially for
something that has been part of YouTube
for so long but I also think that the
data a year later has borne out some of
the original thesis behind and why we
made that change and so I appreciate the
question and I know it's something that
pops up in the community but I I wanted
to address it thoroughly because we have
looked at this pretty closely yeah I
mean it's great that you do have that
data cut up I think it's just hard for a
lot of creators because you know people
have been on the platform for so long
and it's such a drastic change I think
it was definitely hard for a lot of
people to kind of still understand like
why would you do this but I mean I think
it is comforting to know that you guys
do have the data to back that up so that
is great to hear in that same vein is
comment spam I mean I have done so many
giveaways I've been giving away phones
I've been giving away cash on telegram
like all of this stuff it's comical
because these comments are so bad that
the fact that people still fall for them
is kind of disheartening that that's
where people think I would be doing my
giveaways what are you guys doing to
kind of combat this and what can
creators do to protect their audiences
from this type of behavior we have a
really robust investment from a trust
and safety standpoint in terms of going
after these Bad actors I think the
latest numbers I saw was we terminated
on the order of over a 5 million
channels that were in this area and so
we have a pretty robust enforcement
regime but we're also thinking about it
from a product design stand endpoint so
let me give you a few examples one of
the changes that I know you're aware of
that we made was you can no longer hide
the the subscriber count on your channel
right because that was a an abuse Vector
an impersonation Vector we have invested
very heavily in Creator tools moderation
obviously back to the artificial
intelligence machine learning
conversation that is an example of where
we have to make the right trade-offs in
terms of making sure that con comments
are not being over uh held but also
making sure that it's a useful tool for
creators and so we're always tuning that
algorithm and we just introduced a new
control which allows creators if they so
choose to to pick pick a Stricker
stricter standard for comments being
held in review so that's been something
that I think creators have found to be a
valuable tool and then creators can make
a choice in terms of how much they want
to be reviewing comments on their
Channel we just introduced a change I
think a little while back in terms of
minimize using special characters
repetitive characters things like that
which was another Vector that people use
to create channels that would lead to
Common abuse and so those are some of
the product changes above and beyond all
the work that we do on the trust and
safety side there but I'm curious I know
you're part of some of the some of the
betas how's your experience been how's
it been playing out on your channel yeah
I was just going to say I have been a
part of the beta for a couple of months
and it's been significantly so much
better like it's actually kind of
shocking like I can go in and I barely
see any at all so whatever kind of
secret sauce or magic stuff you guys are
doing behind the scenes it definitely
seems like it's working so as a trusted
tester it's been working out pretty well
so I think one of the things that we
always hear is so much talk about the
algorithm and I know there's a ton of
stress with a lot of creators about
chasing views and engagement so what can
you tell us about the algorithm replace
the word algorithm with audience what I
mean by that is the algorithm is a
personalization algorithm that is meant
to reflect the interests of your
audience that is what I would ask
creators to really really think about
and focus on what they're passionate
about for that audience and that is
what's going to result in the best
possible content and it is really the
best possible content that is what gets
recommended over time and and the like
and so it's really about truly
understanding the audience and we are
investing in that in terms of giving
tools to creators so the audience
insights cards for example in studio you
can try to understand the interests of
your audience what other type of content
they're watching but you know you you
asked me the question I think you would
actually be able to answer that question
better than certainly better than I
would so what would be the things that
you would call out given your 17 years
of experience no I love that because I
sometimes like blaming the algorithm
when I know it's a me problem I'm like
but I want to make this type of content
but I know that's not really what my
audience wants to see so I kind of play
this fine line between what do I think
they want and how can I kind of
integrate what I want to do so like I
used to love to Vlog but it seemed like
my audience wasn't enjoying that anymore
so I kind of now wrap a vlog inside of
like a tech review so I'll go out and
test something and go on a little
Adventure so it's just kind of changing
your outlook on like the the type of
content that you're creating and just
know that you can't be creating the same
type of thing all the time like you do
have to evolve and I think that's one of
the questions people always ask me is
like how have you done this for so long
I'm like well I just haven't quit I mean
that's fine line like that's the real
answer because I've had the ups and the
downs and then you just kind of figure
out something new and I think that's why
YouTube is so fun because a lot of us
have that ability to if we want to make
a feature film tomorrow like we can do
that and it's just so great that you
guys are giving us that that ability and
that freedom to do so yeah that's such
an awesome answer and I think that's
what inspires all of us at YouTube to do
what we do because like the your your
whole journey is like what gets us super
fired up and the fact that you get to
do the type of content that you love
find a way for your audience to connect
with it is just like it's just so
awesome to hear so one of the priorities
from last year's letter is you were
talking about nfts now is that still a
focus also just to say I'm actually an
nft fan I love the technology I love the
future thinking the possibilities that
really lie in this Tech and I think if
it's done correctly it can be super
powerful I think the technology is
really interesting as well and I do
think that there's probably lots of
interesting future possibilities a lot
of what we're focused on this year is
you know short form creation mobile tool
mobile creation Etc and so it's less of
a priority for 2023 for us you know
creators shouldn't expect anything
around nft capabilities on their
channels this year and that's really
driven by where our creators interests
are and where their priorities are yeah
definitely sometimes can be quite
negative and it's always really sad
because I can see the possibilities and
I've seen so many incredible projects
come out of the nfg space but I've also
seen the downside the scams and things
like that so it's like you have to be
very careful that when you guys do do it
it's going to be right so I feel like
just knowing that it's in there
somewhere is is pretty exciting for me
one last question before I let you go
there's like having been on YouTube for
so long I know we keep talking about
this there's so many things like little
secrets that I'll be like oh my goodness
I didn't even know that we could do this
now there's things like shopping the
channel subscriptions and so many more
like how do you see all of these
features kind of working together to
help creators the common thread in
everything that we've invested in
especially a lot of these features that
you've described has been really about
helping our creators grow that's
fundamentally what it's about so you
mentioned you know Channel memberships
that is a great way for creators to
really connect with their most engaged
fans and notice I said connect I didn't
say you know monetize because the
monetization piece of course is part of
it growing their businesses but it's
fundamentally about connecting right
giving them access to the backstage
exclusive of content maybe an exclusive
live stream shopping is another example
where you have a lot of content like
this yourself with your tech reviews
lots of people come to YouTube they will
consume your content and they will go
down a purchase Journey or consideration
Journey around a particular product
whether it's a laptop or a headphone or
what have you a means for you to connect
with your audience but also have a
business opportunity there is the way
that we think about shopping and you
know obviously I talked about expanding
our fan funding tier right so that you
can get started generating Revenue even
before you're big enough for advertisers
to be interested through things like
super thanks Etc so all of these are
about making sure that we have ways for
creators to grow regardless of where
they are on their Journey they might
start with a really small you know
shorts Channel or long form Channel and
they might only opt uh monetize through
super things we just brought super
thanks to shorts for example but then
they grow bigger and then they can turn
you know they are part of the ads
program they can generate revenue from
ads they can drive shopping demand or
they move from there to live streaming
and that could be about super chat or
super stickers or Channel memberships
and so it's really about having a basket
of capabilities and features not about
creators using every single one of them
but using the right ones for where they
are in their business today and so
that's that's how I think about it
that's awesome well thank you so much
I'm so glad I got a chance to chat with
you and congrats again on the new roll
super exciting thanks Justine I
appreciated the conversation and look
forward to seeing you in person thanks
so much bye bye now
yeah
foreign
[Music]